[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
MY GUEST TONIGHT, AN AMAZING
COMEDIAN.
HIS NEW FILM IS CALLED "THINK
LIKE A MAN TOO."
>> I'VE BEEN GIVING THIS A LOT
OF THOUGHT.
I WANT YOU TO BE MY BEST MAN.
>> ME?
>> NO, CED, ACTUALLY, I WAS
TALKING TO DOM--
>> NO LISTEN, DON'T SAY NOTHING
RIGHT NOW, MAN.
LIKE, I KNEW YOU AND I HAD A
CONNECTION, BUT THIS IS CRAZY.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, THIS
MEANS SO MUCH TO ME.
I'M NOT GONNA LET YOU DOWN.
LET ME SAY SOMETHING, I'M GOING
TO BE THE BEST BEST MAN
IN THE HISTORY OF ALL
BEST MEN. I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO BE A BEST MAN,
YOU GOING TO GIVE ME THAT
OPPORTUNITY?
WE CAME HERE TO GOLF, AND NOW
YOU GOING TO GIVE ME THIS
BLESSING?
I GOTTA, I GOTTA GO TO THE
BATHROOM, DOM. THIS IS,
♪ THIS LITTLE LIGHT OF MINE.
I'M GOING TO LET IT SHINE.
♪
>> Jon: PLEASE WELCOME KEVIN
HART.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
KEVIN HART.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> Jon: PLEASE, MY FRIEND,
PLEASE.
THEY LOVE YOU. THEY LOVE, IT'S
LOVE.
>> THANK YOU.
THAT'S AMAZING.
THEY'RE VERY NICE.
>> Jon: NICE TO SEE YOU, MY
FRIEND.
>> THANK YOU, MAN.
>> Jon: FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS ON EVERYTHING.
>> THANK YOU, JON.
>> Jon: EVERYTHING.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> Jon: YOU ARE RULING WHAT I
THINK MAY BE THE WORLD.
>>OH WELL, JON, THAT IS AN
AMAZING COMPLIMENT.
>> Jon: IT'S THE KEVIN HART
DECADE.
>> WELL LISTEN, I'M NOT GOING TO
FIGHT THAT.
I'M, I'M HOPING THAT, THAT I CAN
STAY TRUE.
IT'S BEEN A GOOD TIME.
I'M BLESSED. I HAVE LOYAL
FANS...
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> WHO HAVE STUCK WITH ME FROM
DAY ONE AND WHO
HAVE SEEN ME GROW INTO WHAT I AM
NOW AND HOPEFULLY CONTINUE TO
GROW.
SO I THANK YOU ALL, NOT ONLY FOR
THE WELCOMING, BUT FOR THE
SUPPORT.
>> Jon: THEY'RE VERY NICE
PEOPLE.
SO HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. WE COULD SPEND THE TIME
TALKING ABOUT THE MOVIE, BUT YOU
AND I BOTH KNOW...
>> LET'S TALK.
MAN, I'M HERE. I WANNA...
I'M IN YOUR WORLD.
>> Jon: BUT HERE'S WHAT I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT. I DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE MOVIE. I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT...
YOU DID SOMETHING, AND I DON'T
GET TO TALK ABOUT THIS WITH
ANYBODY ELSE HERE.
>> OK.
>> Jon: YOU HOSTED RAW. "MONDAY
NIGHT RAW."
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> HOLY SCHNIKES, YES. YES.
>> Jon: WWE.
>> WWE RAW.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT. SO WHENEVER
I'M HERE, MY SON AND I...
>> OK.
>> Jon: THAT'S ALL WE DO, IS
WATCH WRESTLING.
>> THAT'S ALL YOU ALL DO IS
>> Jon: IT'S THE ONLY WAY I
CAN COMMUNICATE WITH THE BOY...
>> OK.
>> IS THROUGH VIOLENCE.
BUT YOU COME IN HERE AND THEY'RE
ALL LIKE, DID YOU SEE WHAT
HAPPENED ON CNN?
AND I'M LIKE, EVOLUTION BROKE
UP, DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
>> HOW SERIOUS IT IS.
LISTEN, I'M NOT GOING TO LIE TO
YOU, MAN, I'M A FAN.
FIRST OF ALL, I'M A FAN OF
WRESTLING.
>> Jon: YES.
>> AND, I'VE DROPPED OFF,
YOU KNOW, AS I'VE GOTTEN OLDER,
SO...
>> Jon: OH YEAH, NO, ME, TOO.
I'M NOT...
[LAUGHTER]
>> HOW, HOW OLD IS YOUR KID?
HOW OLD IS YOUR KID?
>> Jon: HE'S 23.
>> HE'S 23! WHAT?
>> Jon:, NO, HE'S
NOT. HE'S NOT. HE'S TURNING TEN.
BUT HE'S NINE AND HE
JUST DISCOVERED IT THIS YEAR.
>> NO, THAT'S THE
PERFECT AGE, THOUGH.
THAT'S AROUND THE
AGE THAT I WAS INTO IT, TOO.
>> Jon: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> SO, I CAN SAY ME GOING
HERE BROUGHT BACK ALL THE
MEMORIES OF WHEN I WAS LIKE JUST
ENGULFED IN THIS, IN THIS
SPORT...
>> Jon: WHO WERE THE BIG GUYS
WHEN YOU WERE A KID?
>> WHEN I WAS A KID? OH, DUSTY
RHODES, RIC FLAIR,
JUNK YARD DOG, KOKO B. WARE.
ROAD WARRIORS.
I'M SHOWING MY AGE RIGHT NOW.
>> Jon: OH, YOU WANT SOMEBODY TO
SHOW SOME AGE,
>> I DON'T WANT TO KNOW...
...BRUNO SAN MARTINO, GORILLA
MONSOON, HAYSTACKS CALHOUN.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> JIMMY SUPERFLY SNUKA.
>> I REMEMBER JIMMY...
>> Jon: YOU DO REMEMBER JIMMY?
>> I REMEMBER HIM. CHIEF JAY
STRONGBOW.
>> NO, NO, YOU ARE 1 FOR 6 FOR
ME RIGHT NOW. I KNEW NONE OF
THOSE, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THEY WERE WRESTLERS.
>> Jon: WHAT WAS IT, SO, SO,
DID YOU,
DID THEY WANT TO THROW
YOU? DID YOU DO ANY...
>> THEY CAME OUT, NO, THEY COME
OUT WITH ALL PHYSICAL STUFF
FIRST. HEY, KEVIN, IT'S
GOING TO BE GREAT.
WE'LL GET YOU IN THE RING.
I SAID, WELL, LET'S STOP RIGHT
THERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT. I
SAID, I'M NOT GOING IN THE RING.
I DON'T WANT TO DO ANY STUNTS
WITH THESE GUYS.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> I SAID, NO, LET'S JUST, LET'S
DO SOMETHING WHERE, I CAN,
YOU KNOW, I CAN SHINE. AND IT
WAS LIKE, WHAT DO DO YOU?
ARE YOU FAST?
I WAS LIKE, I CAN TALK.
I SAID, I WANT TO GO AND I WANT
TO COMMENTATE.
LET ME COMMENTATE.
>> Jon: NICE.
>> BUT THAT WAY I
CAN TALK ABOUT THE SPORT,
I CAN BE A PERSONALITY.
SO, THEY'RE LIKE, OKAY, OKAY.
GOOD, WE'LL DO THAT.
AND, I GET THERE, AND THEY SAID,
KEVIN, WE CAME UP WITH SOMETHING
GREAT FOR YOU. WE
CAN GET YOU IN THE RING.
AND I WAS LIKE, WELL, WELL,
LISTEN, I THOUGHT I TOLD
YOU ALL I DIDN'T WANT TO
GET UP IN THAT RING.
YOU KNOW, I JUST DON'T WANT TO
DO IT.
SO I GET IN THE RING AFTER THIS
GUY'S FIGHT, AND, YOU KNOW, HE'S
A DANCER, FANDANGO, IT'S NOT
FANDANGO, IT'S FAN-DAN-GO.
>> Jon: FAN-DAN-GO. YEAH.
>> YEAH. SO, AFTER HE WINS,
YOU KNOW, HE DOES THESE DANCES,
AND HE'S REALLY ENGULFED IN IT,
AND I GET IN AND I DANCE WITH
HIM, BUT THE FUNNY THING IS, THE
ROPES, LIKE, I HAVE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT RESPECT FOR THE ROPES.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GO,
IT'S THE FIRST, THE SECOND AND
THIRD. YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO PULL FIRST TWO APART
AND STEP THROUGH IT.
>> THE FIRST MAN IN HISTORY. I
PULL THE BOTTOM,
I WENT THROUGH... I WENT THROUGH
THE BOTTOM OF THE ROPE.
AND AFTER I DID IT, LIKE, I
DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE I DID IT.
AND, I COME OFF AND ALL THE
WRESTLERS WERE, HEY, THAT WAS
PRETTY FUNNY THE WAY YOU
DID THAT GOING THROUGH
THE BOTTOM THING. AND I WAS
LIKE, WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT? WHAT
WAS FUNNY? IT WAS LIKE, IT
WAS LIKE THAT WAS A BIT, RIGHT?
YOU DID THAT FOR JOKES.
NO, THAT WAS MY LEVEL.
THAT'S, THAT'S WHERE,
THAT'S WHERE I AM.
>> Jon: THAT'S HOW I GET INTO
THIS THING.
>> THAT'S HOW I NATURALLY GOT
INTO IT.
>> Jon: HAVE YOU EVER GOTTEN A
CHANCE, YOU KNOW, IN YOUR
CAREER YOU GET CHANCE TO DO...
YOU'RE PROBABLY LIKE
ME, I'M A HUGE SPORTS FAN.
HAVE YOU GOT AN CHANCE TO GET
INTO ATHLETIC SITUATIONS THAT
HAVE BLOWN YOUR MIND OR MET AN
IDOL OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
>> OH, TONS OF THEM. WELL, JON,
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THIS,
BUT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A TWO-TIME CELEBRITY M.V.P. FOR
THE ALL-STAR WEEKEND.
>> Jon: NO, NO, I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT.
>> YEAH. YES.
>> Jon: AND, WHAT'S YOUR, WHAT'S
YOUR FIELD OF...
>> BASKETBALL. YOU KNOW, IT WAS
A, IT IS A PASTIME, YOU KNOW,
THING OF MINE.
WHATEVER.
I COULD HAVE WENT TO THE LEAGUE.
I CHOSE NOT TO.
>> Jon: NO, I UNDERSTAND, I
UNDERSTAND. SMART CHOICE.
YOU'RE DOING VERY WELL. YOU'RE
DOING VERY WELL.
>> Jon: ME AND YOU SHOULD START
A
LEAGUE FOR THE GENTLEMAN
PLAYER THAT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
THE SIZE...
>> THE SIZE...
>> Jon: YET STILL CONSIDERS
THEMSELVES SOMEWHAT AGILE.
>> WELL, I'M AGILE, BUT THEN YOU
GO TO THE SPORT WHERE YOUR SIZE
WORKS, LIKE SOCCER.
AND, THEN I FIGURED OUT I'M NOT
REALLY THAT FAST. YOU KNOW, SO,
I GOT PROS AND CONS FOR
EVERYTHING I'VE DONE.
I BOX. AND, I WAS REALLY
GOOD WHEN I HAD A TRAINER.
>> Jon: YEAH, YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, BUT I JUST HIT HIS
HANDS, AND HE WAS LIKE, YOU
KNOW, IT WAS NOTHING ELSE.
IT WAS JUST HIS HANDS.
AND I WAS LIKE, YO, I'M REALLY
GOOD. AND, YOU KNOW,
I WAS LIKE, YO, I'M FAST.
MY TIMING IS GREAT.
>> Jon: YEAH, YEAH.
>> AND ONE DAY WE WERE DOING IT,
AND, YOU KNOW, HE DID THIS.
HE'S NEVER DONE THIS EVER.
HE'S NEVER... LISTEN, WE TRAINED
SO MUCH.
NOT ONCE HAS HE EVER DONE THIS,
BUT I GUESS HE EXPECTED A NASTY
REACTION. SO, YOU KNOW, I'M LIKE
ONE-TWO-THREE,
ONE-TWO, BOP-BOP-BOP.
AND HE WENT LIKE THIS.
AND, IT HIT ME.
I STOPPED.
I TOOK MY GLOVES OFF.
I SAID, WHAT IS THAT ABOUT?
WHEN DID WE START FIGHTING BACK?
LIKE, WHAT IS THAT?
I WAS PISSED OFF.
I WAS LIKE, DUDE, I'M DONE,
I'M NOT, LIKE I'M DONE WITH THIS
SESSION.
>> Jon: THIS IS NOT BOXING.
>> HE WAS LIKE, KEVIN, THIS IS
FOR YOU TO DUCK. I WAS LIKE,
FIRST OF ALL, THAT'S NOT. THAT'S
A PUNCH, WHAT YOU DID.
THAT'S A PUNCH.
HE'S LIKE, I THOUGHT YOU WOULD
DUCK.
WELL, YOU THOUGHT WRONG, AND YOU
ALSO JUST GOT DOCKED.
I DEDUCTED AN AMOUNT. THAT'S
ABOUT IT.
>> Jon: NO, I THINK THAT'S
WISE. WELL, VERY NICE.
IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE COME BACK
AND SEE US.
>> I HAVE TO, MAN!
>> Jon: THE MOVIE, "THINK LIKE A
MAN TOO," IT'S IN THE THEATERS
ON FRIDAY.
>> YES!
>> THE ALWAYS WONDERFUL KEVIN
HART.
>> THANK YOU, MAN.